or they put like money on the floor next
to your car with the same I don't know
what it is that they're putting on these
bills I found this on the floor today
touch it touch it slowly pass out are
you feeling okay
[Music]
okay can everybody try as hard as you
can to get into your most merciful state
of mind right now merciful yeah maximum
Mercy please before you hear this okay
does this guy deserve the second chance
that uh he uh currently is trying to act
like he has I know it sounds weird but
listen to this there's a guy who uh
he's 37 he's from Virginia
randomly he decided to walk into this
window store
and he murdered the manager who's like a
65 year old man stabbed him over 50
times uh he ended up being found not
guilty because a way of insanity right
okay so then he was you know of course
that meant that he would be uh he was in
jail for a little bit but he got out on
conditional bail
and now people have started to see him
on dating sites
okay I have so he's walking the streets
he's not like you know mental I have two
questions so the first one so this is
like a store where they sell Windows
like only Windows they get Blackboard or
something you know like uh like a guy
who a guy who makes windows will install
them for you one of those guys yeah they
got those yeah it's like what's with all
these murders getting away with pleading
Insanity like oh look at this this is
why he's uh got away with Insanity
because he goes in there and he thinks
in his head that the Windows store
manager is a werewolf
yeah
so in his mind he's doing us a service
so what if he finds but what if he finds
another werewolf and then kills them too
exactly in my most merciful State I say
kill that [ __ ] that's the best
because the way that I think I think the
most merciful state that I would be I
would have to put myself in Mother
Nature's shoes and in mother's Nature's
shoes I gotta be merciful to the rest of
Mother Nature yeah so if you have
something that is extremely violent
towards the rest of the species and is a
danger to the rest of the species we
need to stop cancer where it starts so
it's like you know like a kernel like
corn on the cob yeah the minute that one
kernel turns purple you gotta pull that
purple one up you know all right so
that's what I think so I'm like that
fool's dead it made my most merciful
State look at this so here's his um
here's his dating profile by the way and
this is the reason why people are pissed
it's not because he's out and dating
it's because of what he wrote on it all
right look at Werewolf hunter he says
an easy going adventurer who believes in
Universal connection with all and love
to explore and try new things also
recently getting back from two years of
traveling which is not true it's his
jail is jail in court traveling to jail
and probably a mental institution
that's still a trip
so this guy basically is technically
still considered a danger to society by
just the average populace and when you
see that picture you're just like oh
he's an adventurous guy look he likes
waterfalls I like hiking and jumping
into waterfalls like I totally go with
them and then you find out he's a
[ __ ] murderer yeah so while there's
no love Werewolf hunter oh yeah trying
to watch it man there's no there's no
law prohibiting somebody from like being
on a dating profile when they're on
probation or they're on uh what's it
called conditional bail yeah is this
right no I think it's [ __ ] Hold on
hold on we got to put on our Mercy hats
right Mercy hats no man what if
this guy is actually a true werewolf
yeah what if it he wasn't and nobody
believes him nobody believes him he's on
to something here like we've watched all
those
move you gotta believe me and then
they're like nah he's stupid let's put
him in jail and then like the real
werewolves start [ __ ] us up yeah
because if I was a werewolf I'd disguise
in a window shop
what if this is like season five of a
werewolf killing show and that's like
the main boss and he's been like
surviving immortality he didn't even
know what a window shop was of course
it's the perfect disguise right because
no one it's very unassuming right it's
not like he had a nothing but silver
jewelry shop you know but silver you
named it for him already there used to
be a shop called Nothing But silver at
the mall I don't remember that [ __ ] yeah
it used to be called Nothing But silver
do you think then what's what's a good
compromise do you think a guy like this
should say on his profile that he was
recently no he can't see that like
that's that's the only fault I've seen
this year if the guy wants to date the
two years of traveling like come on why
do you gotta even put that I think I
would have more Mercy if he's put
Werewolf hunter or I've been in jail
there's some [ __ ] that's like actually
honest that would be catchy though if I
was scrolling through a dating app and
someone was like oh I was in jail for
two years because I'm a werewolf Hunter
like really fun guy I'd be like okay and
then on the crazy but now he's crazy and
he's a liar let's say that you liked
that and you were like what a quirky
dude you guys go out first date he goes
hey that stuff about the werewolf thing
it's true I am on conditional bail uh
was released for due to Insanity I
killed a guy
if I was a vampire if I was a vampire
girl I'd be like oh where have you been
all my life girl you mean no because
then vampires hate [ __ ] werewolves
right so he is a werewolf Hunter perfect
this is where's the [ __ ] love it's a
reverse toilet where the girl is the
vampire and he's a werewolf Hunter
except he's really hunting werewolves I
just can't believe he didn't get
sentenced or anything yeah that's
ridiculous yeah why do murderers always
have really good lawyers
over 50 times man and always like oh
like so many times just like like well
it also does make sense if he's a
werewolf and he has a window store
because that's where werewolves Escape
they see the moon they go oh
[Music]
and they open the window and they climb
out so he makes portals for what his
other brothers
yeah very intelligent or maybe you have
to stop him 50 times because he was so
powerful that he wouldn't die
he should have used a silver knife I
like that I like that did he even use a
silver knife I don't know he's a
werewolf Hunter so probably I hope
expert pop dogs especially if he's in
the middle of morphing where he's like
breaking out of his shirt oh yeah he's
half morph yeah they're really really
strong I'm just surprised that someone
can kill someone even like through
cleaning a insanity but they're out in
the real world like just chilling
because we always heard that like when
you plead Insanity you don't always get
a better scenario sometimes Mental
Hospitals are worse than being in jail
why isn't he a mental health or he went
and then well here's the thing I'll read
it to you right now they say that uh
after his arrest he was incarcerated
hospitalized for extended period and
then he worked exceedingly hard
throughout his treatment due to his
progress in the hospital they agreed
that uh he was granted Court approved
conditional release they were like hey
you're good enough to at least be out
and you know that's part of his
Rehabilitation I don't know man I think
it was just paid off and then he makes a
[ __ ] dating profile the crazy thing
is that like that's true to life when
like women are looking at profiles I'm
like oh this guy could be a murderer and
this time to write where is the
werewolves family think I know yeah you
already killed them all yeah
were you ever afraid about a serial
killers and stuff when you go out there
dating and stuff because I always think
about that I was like damn it must suck
like girls got to be careful yeah I feel
like even especially now like I don't
know I feel like it's a weird time in
the world a lot of crime and stuff but
it's definitely a thing I mean you're a
young girl and you know you meet up with
some random guy you got to be cautious
and stuff you know keep your location on
touch your friends know where you're
going the weirdest thing I think right
now not like the dating stuff but like
how people are putting like the air tags
on people's cars oh the zip ties like
the sex trafficking [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is like
really really bad right now it's crazy
it's and it's like everywhere
I think yeah because now they're telling
like chicks like when you go out to your
car you gotta look underneath you might
have a stalker like the air tax while
they try to find where you live I've had
notification on my phone where it's like
an unknown Air Attack has been detected
and I've had to like search my stuff wow
the [ __ ] that's that's a thing they're
doing and they'll follow you home they
know where you live to your car or they
put like a little zip tie they've been
doing things where um they'll like put
something on like your window or your
handle and if you go to grab it there's
like they put some sort of drug on it
that seeks into your skin and then you
get like all like
the tissue stuff or they put like money
on the floor next to your car with the
same I don't know what it is that
they're putting on these bills I found
this on the floor today touch it touch
it slowly pass out are you feeling okay
oh I shouldn't touch it it's crazy
people have been putting fentanyl on oh
no and if people grab it like it soaks
into your skin it like knocks you out uh
what app is it that can detect if
there's an air tag on you it's not an
app it's your phone yeah just the Apple
software wow
um if you have an Apple phone it'll be
like sometimes it glitches though a
little bit like I feel like I've gotten
in I haven't found anything it's scary
to know that it's detecting sometimes I
wish women were all armed and they were
violent because I feel so bad like we
can't help we can't do nothing and then
I just feel like oh why can't you just
kill him when you get caught you know
like a man like just imagine if like
they're like like hey and then she's
like boom you know and it's like oh and
everyone's like yeah
if I'm like in Hollywood or something
and like if I ever feel like I'm being
followed uh you act crazy you're like I
[ __ ] myself one of them you would
actually do that no but I would if that
would happen but like think about that
yeah you just like yeah act like you're
not okay like who's gonna want to kidnap
that somebody good method is to just rip
a huge fart
turn those people off of me
someone's following you just I heard if
you can if you could do like vomit on
call just [ __ ] puke on wow these are
very demanding uh ways of getting away
that's hard yeah I don't know I just I
just know that there was this thing that
was going down where um people would be
live streaming to
like they'll be going into a market or
some [ __ ] like Target or some [ __ ] right
Walmart they'll follow girls and then
the girl would be like on a live just
just be like what about this one what
about that one and then when they find
one she'll be like all right she's
coming out and then like there'll be
guys outside in the parking lot with a
van and that's how they catch them
there's this new thing too also where
they're doing this thing where
um they'll have like a young girl
working for them and they'll like knock
on someone's house or apartment like hey
um I need help my car's not starting or
like or like someone's following me
please like open the door call 9-1-1 and
they'll wait for the person to come out
and they have guys ready that'll just
like
that happened snatch the person or
whatever that happens back in the late
70s early 80s he was part of a gang in
LA and he was downtown some girl hit on
him and so she uh she basically learned
him in to hook up but then there were
two dudes waiting and they kidnapped him
for ransom so my my grandfather had to
show up with some cash to get him out
holy [ __ ] dude yeah who told you this
story your dad your grandpa my mom oh
mom told me so that's why I know your
mom was the girl then
[Music]